expand by becoming someone else you  expand by becoming more of who you are  and i think this is important because a  lot of people who are trying to like  become influencers or trying to create  content they say i want to be like him  or i want to look like this or i want to  be that guy of my space but the thing is  it's like you don't want to be the that  guy of your space you just want to be  the you of your space because at the end  of the day people just believe in  authenticity and authenticity is the  alignment of three things it's your  thoughts your words and your actions if  what you truly believe is what you are  truly saying and you're living in  accordance with that you will be  authentic and the only way to do that is  to just be you